I think the last time we saw Johnny
Manziel in person we were in the New
York City man cave and he brought in the
Highsmith trophy with him Johnny Manziel
joins us now Johnny how are you this
morning what uh it seems like a long
time ago when you came into the man cave
with that Heisman Trophy what do you
remember about that whole weekend a
little bit of a blur I feel like I did
every radio show every TV show
everything that was possible to do after
the Heisman but I do remember coming in
I do remember bringing the trophy to be
honest it has been a long time where is
that Highsmith trophy oh it's in East
Texas you what do you think when you see
it I walk in and go back and visit my my
my grandma sometimes my my grandma's
house and Tyler and I definitely put the
smile on my face I definitely remember
you know just how fun that season was
how fun that was playing any SEC that
first year
how old special her on that was with
guys that were so good it's so fun to be
around and I'll never forget being in
New York and her announcing it the
seconds after that the look on my
parents face yeah the anticipation and
build-up before she told my dame was it
was unbelievable you make your debut in
the developmental spring league coming
up April 7th the spring league debut
will broadcast on Turner Sports new
streaming service Bleacher port report
live more excited or more nervous for
your debut I'm definitely more excited
it's it's obviously a two week you know
a week of training can't play a game
four or five more days of practice and
in in training camp and play another
game so it's it's quick but at the same
time I have to have a step forward after
being out of football for two years so I
have to get back around in a playbook
get around guys throwing really moving
routes with linemen in my say
like this is step one to getting back to
where I need to be even though it's not
you know it's not the exact equivalent
of where where I want to be but I feel
what the way everything is being run
with the coaches we have here with the
guys we have here this is a step in the
right direction for what young guys need
you know when a training camp gets cut
down from 90 guys in OTAs to 45 or 654
sorry where the rest of those guys go
yeah some go to the practice squad some
go to Canada but there's a lot of guys
who have gone through the last six years
of their life thinking that the NFL is
going to be their job and and when it
comes down to it the reality of the
situation is it's not and you know it's
something I feel like you know the NFL
pro football developing guys because a
lot of the guys who are on the roster
especially quarterbacks don't get a
chance to really play during the season
preseason is really only all you get so
I think this is a great idea I'm not all
that nervous I'm sure I will be a little
bit on Saturday but it's a step in the
right direction
getting back reading coverages seeing
defenses and had it fun you know that's
around talking some crap on the field
and getting back to what it used to be
how close were you to going to the CFL
it was it was definitely close you know
I feel like earlier this year we got the
okay to go to Canada started negotiating
with them they kind of slacked on the
negotiations a little bit we gave what
we wanted it didn't get Matt we said we
had other options these were one of
those other options and it's no
disrespect to them or that League just
its business at the end of the day what
we wanted did it get you know met and we
told them we had other options
this was another option and and it's
know a step in the right direction as
far as I can't play a CFL game and so
June July whenever they start this gets
me to games training camp everything in
April so there's still a chance you
could play in the Canadian Football
League
very much so how confident are you in
your skills do it two years off just
being back around right now I don't
notice any any difference you know I
obviously is there some rust to be
shaken off as there's some coverages and
stuff that let's sort of pick yesterday
where this guy takes two steps down to
like the hits when you're rolling left
on like a smash POW and takes two steps
down well he takes those two steps down
my instinct started to plummet to the
corner the guy's just completely baited
me took two steps down and then
completely bailed and picked me off and
that's just part of what I need no I
need some some failure in practice as
far as throwing some things making some
mistakes so whenever I get back to where
I want to be you know I've learned from
that but that's just part of the game so
it'll be interesting to see how this
plays out I'm really excited I mean this
is always well for me right now I'm
happy with where things are going am i
personalized
I'm happy with where things are going
football wise even though there's a
little bit of a question mark behind it
but a lot better than where I was he's
Johnny Manziel the spring league south
quarterback do you got a nickname this
team got a nickname nah we're just the
sounds we're doing it north east south
west one jersey killer who were the
black squad so it's been fun and the
guys I've had on my team the other
quarterback that's on my team we've all
meshed really well we've all you know
had a lot of fun the last couple days
I'm playing with a couple guys that
played in Arkansas a couple that play to
Baylor like you know one the play to
Texas so it's it's it's it's a lot of
fun and I really am enjoying it it's fun
getting up going to meetings having to
having a similar day to what it is in
the NFL it's not the exact same but you
know for for the setting that we're in
it's it's close if I gave you a mulligan
during your rookie year what would
you've done differently
um I would have started due to given me
the Mulligan the mowing would have had
to come right after I got blasted I see
successful guys in the NFL and what they
do in the offseason and the time that
they put in that makes them good players
yes they're athletic ly gifted but guys
are good in the NFL because they know
film they study hard and they work even
harder in the offseason so I didn't know
that and I still like if Cleveland did
any of their homework they would have
known that I thought was a guy that
didn't come in every day and watch film
I was a guy that didn't really know the
X's and O's of a football I played the
spread offense we looked at bubbles we
looked at flats we had progression reads
across the field it wasn't like it was a
super intricate like pro system so so
when I get to Cleveland you know I have
a quarterback in the room with me that's
that's not helping me and it's not
really his job to but nobody was there
like helping me go over the X's and O's
and it was it was home and I struggled
and then getting on the practice field I
lost a lot of confidence after my first
couple days there like this was the
first time of my life
police and / freshman year in high
school that I wasn't playing really well
yeah I didn't come out the first day and
throw the ball around and make a lot of
completions and scored touchdowns and
everything I struggled and from there
you know that's when the Depression
started to come that's when some things
mental health wise started to started to
really change what was going on in my
life but I would go back to after the
draft and getting with someone or
putting in extra time or whatever it was
to make sure that I really genuinely
understood everything that was going on
there was a lot of winging it and not a
lot of you know knowing exactly what I
was doing because it was a hard
transition for me I didn't know
everything and the next year when I got
with Josh McCown
I was like listen if you want you can
come with me everyday you can get here
when I get here
you can leave when I leave if you want
to be good just follow what I'm doing
I've been doing this for a long time and
there's a reason that I'm still in the
league this long down the road and me
and him got along great
he's a good dude he's awesome he really
is he's unbelievable gave me a great he
gave me a great blueprint and that's
something I still had to this day he
gave me a nice blueprint of what it
takes to be a solid pro and I'm very
thankful for Josh and him doing all that
he did for me Cleveland but do you think
you were winging it on the field and
then winging it off the field a little a
little bit of both I feel like I turned
and enjoyed everything that was going on
because of what I had done football wise
all the access everything that I had had
done from football and stop focusing on
football itself and I don't know if I
was just tired or just like overwhelmed
with everything that was going on with
my life I don't I'm not going to make an
excuse for it at the end of the day it's
completely my fault and how I treated my
job as far as being a first-round pick
and a guy they wanted to come in and
turn the franchise around you know I
didn't work hard enough to be that guy
and it's a regret I'm gonna have to live
with yeah I remember talking to somebody
and I don't want to say somebody close
to you because you know that's there is
somebody who knew you and they said we
just keep waiting for him to hit rock
bottom it's gonna take that for him to
realize because people were trying to
tell you what was going on
you know we even had Ryan Leaf reach out
to you because we thought he had hit
rock bottom he had gone to prison you
know he was stealing prescription drugs
when he was an assistant coach and we
thought maybe he could help you do you
remember the rock bottom day I do it was
late 2016 you know I thought everything
that I did in early 2016 after I got cut
you know I I try got to drop by my agent
February
2016 I signed with another agent I was
in 14 you know I wasn't out of the mix
by any means you know what the observe
data was going on in my life and
whenever people were tall and whenever I
would talk to some teams it just didn't
make me light up like it did in the past
like I was just super just off and I
didn't know if I wanted to continue
doing that and I questioned if that's
what I wanted to do and I remember
getting into later on that year all the
things I thought I wanted to do and
thought I would make me happy just left
me empty and just and did it and I
thought everything off the field would
make me happy and traveling and go to
these places in LA and Miami and going
out every night I thought that's what
really was going to bring joy and
happiness to my life and all I did was
make me miserable alone depressed and in
questioning my entire life my entire
existence and in it it was hard it was
really hard I don't think about it as
much anymore I guess because I've been
lucky enough to turn a little bit of a
corner
think about you know how low it really
got because it was scary
you know we saw things that my dad said
look people thought you were gonna kill
me
dad people thought you were gonna kill
yourself somehow someone somehow someway
that's that's what it looked like it was
one one step after another towards
destruction how's married life it's new
it's definitely no it's good I'm very
happy with that I'm very happy with her
and everything that she is brought into
my life a sense of you know happiness
that I haven't felt in a while because I
want to be where I'm at today I want to
be at the springle I wouldn't be in the
shape that I meant I wouldn't be in a
mental state that I'm in right now if it
wasn't for her and you know I have to
give her a lot of credit because credit
is due there and I got lucky you know I
didn't know or think that this would be
my path at 25 years old help obviously I
was in college and when I was in my
first year the league like I really
wasn't looking like being married in
four years three years
but I'm very happy I feel I got very
lucky and I'm very fortunate I have a
girl that loves me and it doesn't know a
lot about what I've done in the past
football-wise
she's not a huge sports person I think
that's what makes our relationship so
good last time an NFL team contacted you
I mean I was at A&M Pro take a couple
weeks ago there's still been guys around
the league that have checked in on me
over the course of the last couple weeks
to a month so you know I've stayed in
constant contact with some people since
January so it doesn't take for me moving
forward it
it doesn't take 32 teams to try like me
and want to sign me it just takes ones
that that's willing to take you know a
little bit of a chance I understand that
it's a little bit of a risk I understand
that people think you know there's a
little bit of uncertainty with how I you
know behavior has fluctuated over the
years but you know I'm sitting here I'm
25 years old
I'm healthy and where I'm at both
physically and mentally and you know I
feel like if I get into a good situation
which is not what I was in the first
time if I get into a good situation with
people who are willing to you know
handle me the right way you know I can't
do anything about how it is like media
wise when I come somewhere and it's a
big deal when people are asking
questions do it I just can't do it like
I have no say over that but as far as
everything else coming into the building
doing the right thing every day being
the hard in practice like practicing
hard doing everything you're supposed to
do in the you know on the boardroom and
things like got a meeting rooms I can do
that you know I'm healthy mentally
physically and I look forward to an
opportunity wherever that may be how
long you been sober
it's been about four months or month are
we in now is is April generates or yeah
about four months I don't like to really
sit and not a big day counter you know I
can sit there and be able to off the top
of my head tell you exactly how many day
it is days it is I know the date I take
my approach
and it's a corny thing to do but every
day I wake up you get through that day
you take it step by step you're just
focused like right now I wake up I had
this with you and I go to meetings and
then we're gonna practice and then we
come back have a lunch with all the
quarterbacks go to more meetings come
back go see my wife go see my family
that lives in Austin and make it through
that day and then put you know I've had
five six four days of practice right now
just stack them together
I've had five six days in a row off the
field stack them together and keep it
going because that's all I really can't
do and if you take that daily approach
eventually you stack up enough good days
to where you've seen some real progress
and anybody who has had substance abuse
will tell you that it's one day at a
time and nobody's here to judge you you
judge yourself and your wife will judge
you but you know what you've already had
some wins along the way if you've gotten
to this point you know you're 25 you're
healthy and you got a chance again
you're married you seem happy you're
sober so you've had some wins already if
I talk to you in five years
what's our conversation like so we get
one conversation every five years yeah I
think we can do it yearly Johnny but I'm
just saying five years down the road
you're 30 years ago I'm you know
hopefully I'm still playing football but
beyond all that beyond football you know
I hope I'm I'm with a family I hope I
have a family I hope I'm sober I hope
I'm continuing to take the medication I
have to for my mental health
I hope I'm progressing as a person and
to try and figure out what life is
because I don't have it figured out I'm
in a lot better place than I was no I
don't know you know how long it'll take
that we figure it out if ever but
nevertheless progressing as a person you
know I want to have a family I want to
move forward in my personal life and you
know I want to continue to fight this
battle it doesn't matter for me if as
anybody knows Dikshit you can have years
and years and years under
well and it one day you know one one
time let your guard down and annek at
all it can all unravel that's a scary
thing about it and you know making sure
that's a priority daily and hourly is is
key because without that without the
mental health pieces without taking care
of that everything else goes out the
window
you sell me not sure player what I'm
doing that I I think you know you sit on
mature we got to change it to John
Manziel let's get rid of children can we
get rid of Johnny Manziel here and just
call you John Manziel plenty one of our
coach one of our coaches in the spring
is definitely calling me John man's on
it's pretty funny I think it's your
Thomas might have suggested this a
couple years ago yeah we got to get rid
of that guy you know just John Manziel
just sounds like all business there I
agree
hey good luck have fun and you know it's
step by step and their wins every day
for you so hopefully you get a chance
and you know we look forward to there
are a lot of people rooting for you and
you have to understand that I've
definitely felt that sometimes I
definitely get locked on to negativity
or see negativity but when it comes down
to it when I go through Twitter I go
through certain things see certain
things here are certain things in the
streets you know people are way more
positive than they are negatives me
especially you know that narrative has
changed a little bit as of late and I'm
thankful for that
I'm thankful for all the people that
have supported me and continue to
support me I am through my my downfall
and now trying to take it step by step
and the long road back so you know I
appreciate you for having me I enjoyed
it and have a good rest of the day hug
your wife man that's important as you
move forward and thanks for joining us
joining yes sir all right Johnny Manziel
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]